この章では、コンピューター環境について
考えるためのフレームワークをご紹介します。
このフレームワークは、ノートパソコンにも
スーパーコンピューターにも応用できます。
この章を終えると、
コンピューターリソースの基本的な概念と
それらの関係性を理解できるようになります。
では、コンピューターリソースとは何でしょうか？簡単に言うと、
コンピューターシステムを構成するコンポーネントのことです。
まず、CPU（中央処理装置）があります。
CPUはほとんどの命令を実行します。次にメモリ、
つまりRAMがあり、データを一時的に保持します。
そしてプログラムの命令も格納します。
また、GPU（グラフィックス処理装置）もあります。
GPUはグラフィックスレンダリング向けに設計されていますが、
汎用コンピューティングタスクにも利用できます。
特に大量の並列処理が必要な
科学シミュレーション、データ分析、機械学習などに適しています。
これらのリソースは連携してプログラムを実行します。
それぞれに固有の計測単位があります。
たとえば、CPUはコア数と
クロックスピードで計測され、メモリはバイト単位で計測されます。
ギガ、メガ、テラバイトといった単位です。
各問題を解くにあたって、
必要なリソースのセットが
実行のために求められます。
プログラムを効率よく実行するためのリソース要件、
プログラムの各コンポーネントが実行される場所、
そしてそれらをつなぐインフラの帯域幅は、
全体的なパフォーマンスを
決定する上で重要な役割を果たします。
たとえば、GPUがプログラムの特定の部分を高速に計算できても、
GPUのメモリへのプログラム読み込みに時間がかかる場合は、
それよりも
CPUを使った方が速いこともあります。では、
クラシカルリソースのスケーリングについて話しましょう。
アプローチは2つあります。垂直スケーリングと
水平スケーリングです。垂直スケーリングとは、
単一リソースの性能を高めることで、
より強力なCPUや多くのメモリを使用するなど、
1つの物理ノード内で行います。
ノードとは、コンピュータークラスターの構成単位で、
複数のリソースを内包します。水平スケーリングとは、
複数のCPUやGPUなど、
リソースを追加して
1つまたは複数のノードで協調動作させることです。
どちらのアプローチにもそれぞれ利点と
欠点があり、選択は具体的なユースケース
と要件によって異なります。ここで新しいリソースを紹介しましょう。
量子リソースです。量子リソースは量子情報を処理します。
QPU（量子処理装置）を使用します。QPUとは
実行可能な量子命令セット、
つまり量子 circuit を受け取り、
正確な結果を返す責任を持つ
システム全体のことです。つまり、
QPUには1枚以上の量子チップが含まれます。
たとえば、IBM量子ヒアーや
その他の複数のコンポーネントが
希釈冷凍機の中に収められており、
量子チップを冷却しています。
量子増幅器や制御エレクトロニクスなど、
また、命令の保持などのタスクに必要な
クラシカルコンピューターも含まれます。
メモリ上の波形データの保持、結果の蓄積、
そして将来的なエラー訂正デコードにも使われます。
一般に、量子リソースは
品質（レイヤードフィデリティスケール）、
qubit 数、
そして速度（circuit レイヤー演算数／秒、
CLOPSと呼ばれる）で計測されます。本日は量子チップを
計測単位として扱います。リソース管理システムがGPUを
コア数ではなく
装置全体として扱うのと同様の考え方です。スケーリングについては、
クラシカルリソースと同様に、量子リソースのスケーリングも
垂直と水平に分類できます。
垂直スケーリングとは、
チップレットまたはチップあたりの qubit 数を増やすことです。
あるいはチップ単体の
水平スケーリングとは、チップを
量子カプラーまたはクラシカル相互接続で接続することです。
こうした定義を踏まえた上で、
リソース管理についてお話しましょう。
コンピューターインフラにおけるリソース管理とは、
計算リソースの利用を計画し、
割り当て、管理するプロセスのことです。
CPU、メモリ、ストレージ、
ネットワーク帯域幅などを効率的かつ
効果的に活用することを目的としています。
リソース管理は、
テトリスの多次元版のようなものと考えられます。各ブロックが
ジョブの要件に対応し、
各次元がリソース単位を表します。基本的なタスクは、
これらのジョブブロックを利用可能な全リソースという
立方体にうまく収めることです。リソース管理は
非常に複雑なタスクで、コンピューター施設ごとに
インフラ構成の戦略が異なります。
それぞれのユーザーベースの固有のニーズに合わせています。
今学んだ概念を実際に適用するために、
Slurm を使います。Slurm はオープンソースの
リソース管理ソフトウェアです。
デモ用に、
3つの仮想ノードからなるローカル環境を用意しました。
これらのコンピューターノードの情報は、
scontrol コマンドを実行することで確認できます。
2つのパーティション（ノードグループ）があります。
normal と quantum です。normal パーティションはクラシカルリソースのみに
アクセスできるノードで構成されています。
quantum パーティションは量子リソースにアクセスできます。
まずシンプルな
クラシカルな Hello World の例を Slurm で試してみましょう。
まず Hello World プログラム自体が必要です。
こちらが Hello World を表示するだけのプログラムです。
Hello World と表示します。
次に、リソースマネージャーに対して
このプログラムの実行に必要なリソースを伝える必要があります。
先ほど説明したように、Slurm ではジョブのメタデータを
指定する方法が用意されています。
それはシェルスクリプトで、
Slurm 固有のアノテーションが付いています。
このアノテーションにより、リソース要件や
スケジューリングパラメーターなどを指定できます。
提出スクリプトを確認してみましょう。
パーティションの指定、
必要なノード数、ノードあたりのタスク数、
タスクあたりのCPU数を指定します。
そして実行するスクリプトも指定します。
こちらが Hello World プログラムです。
ジョブを実行キューに提出するには、コマンドを1つ実行するだけです。
sbatch コマンドを使い、
スクリプトを引数として渡します。
実行キューを確認すると、
Hello World プログラムが動いているのがわかります。
normal パーティションの node-c1 上で実行中です。
ジョブが完了したら、結果を確認できます。
出力ファイルを見てみましょう。
以上です。
次に量子リソースの使い方も見てみましょう。
シンプルな Hello Qiskit プログラムを作ってみます。
こちらが Qiskit プログラムで、
circuit の作成、
最適化、実行、後処理に必要なすべてのステップが含まれています。
ここに、これまで説明してきたプログラミングの概念が
すべて含まれています。量子 circuit の transpiler 処理、
そして Qiskit primitives です。
次に提出スクリプトを作成します。
先ほどと同様ですが、ここでは
量子リソースの要件を指定します。
リソースを指定したので、
クラスター上のパーティションと
利用可能な量子リソースを指定すると、
Qiskit primitives は
割り当てられたリソースを使って量子処理を実行します。
それでは、プログラムを実行してみましょう。
ジョブが完了したら、結果を確認できます。
こちらが期待値です。
リソース管理についての説明は以上です。
次のセクションでは、
プログラミングモデルについてお話しします。